Malaria is a disease that's spread by mosquitoes
and involves a parasite that grows inside red blood
cells. Now the parasite that causes malaria called
plasmodium is able to easily infect normally shaped red
blood cells. But the sickle shaped cells are
harder for the parasite to infect. And even when
it does infect it, the cell bursts open before
the plasmodium has finished its life cycle. Having even
one copy of the sickle cell mutation, or the
HbS allele, increases resistance to malaria, because a few
of the cells are going to be more sickle
shape. Thus providing at least a little bit of
resistance to plasmodium infection. So although the HbS allele
was recessive for sickle cell anemia, it's actually dominant
with regards to malaria resistance. This means that an
individual allele, a single allele could be dominant or
recessive depending on which trait you're looking at. I
mean, think about it. We have one allele, the HbS
allele. But there are two different traits. We can either
think about the sickle cell anemia trait. Or malaria resistance
trait. In one case this allele is recessive because you
need two copies before you really see the effect. But
in the case of malaria resistance only one copy is
enough to resist plasmodium infection, making it a dominant allele.
Hopefully this adds another layer of complexity. To
how we've been thinking about single, individual alleles.
Remember, one allele can have an effect on
lots of traits. So in this scenario, if we
have no copies of the HbS allele, we're
going to be more susceptible to plasmodium infection and
malaria. One copy makes you more resistant to
malaria, but may give you mild symptoms of anemia
from some limited sickling of cells. But two
copies of the HbS allele would result in
full sickle cell anemia, which typically can reduce
a person's lifespan and even cause death during childhood.
So in an area plagued by malaria, like
Sub-Saharan Africa, which genotype do you think would
have the greatest fitness, or the greatest probability
of survival? HbA HbA, HbA HbS, or HbS HbS